hey guys i'm rahul from simply learn and
welcome to the session on aws
certification
in this session i'll be telling you
about several things
like why aws is so important next
we'll talk about the job roles in aws
the career path to become an aws
solutions architect
the certifications that are available in
aws and companies that are hiring in
2020
also guys if you have any questions
regarding the topic or aws
let us know in the comment section below
our team of experts
will help you as soon as possible now
before we get on to this
let's talk about why or what exactly is
aws aws or amazon web services
is a cloud computing platform that
offers more than 175 different services
across several domains now among the
several cloud service providers in the
market right now like microsoft azure
vmware rackspace and so on aws is more
commonly used than any of its
competitors
but what makes aws so special why must
you get certified by them
so to answer our earlier question let's
have a look at 2019's third quarter's
cloud market share
which is provided by canalis now aws
dominated the cloud service market share
with 32 of the entire share and it had a
growth of over 2.3 billion dollars
year over year now you can see in the
graph here that azure and gcp only
account for 17 percent and seven percent
respectively the others like rackspace
and
ibm cloud are contributing 44 percent
now if you do need more convincing as to
choosing aws
let me give you more reasons why firstly
it provides pay-as-you-go pricing which
means you only pay for how much you use
now you use what you need and then the
costs are scaled
automatically and accordingly now for
example
say you use ec2 which provides virtual
machines
you only use for how much virtual
machines you've created and how long you
use them
aws is also very secure now this
provides
end-to-end privacy and security and
storage
aws also has experience now aws has over
four years of leg up over other cloud
service providers
like microsoft azure this means over the
years
they have skills and infrastructure
management that can
give you more next aws is also very
flexible
this allows users to select their
operating system language
database and other services with great
ease
aws is also very easy to use you can
host your applications very quickly
and securely whether it's existing or a
completely new application
aws is also extremely scalable
now if you're a small scale company you
don't need a lot of resources
aws understands that and scales down if
you're a larger organization
obviously you're going to need a lot
more resources ewps can help with that
as well
now let's talk about the job roles
within aws
now here are some of them there are
these aren't all of them
but we have aws cloud architect sysops
administrator
cloud developer system integrator cloud
devops engineer
solutions architect network specialist
and big data specialist
now getting each of these roles becomes
much easier
when you're certified by aws
now let's talk about the steps you need
to take so that you can become
an aws solutions architect now we are
selecting this one because this is one
of the most common
and talked about job roles in aws
now most of the job job roles i
mentioned earlier
have similar steps but but with a few
steps added or removed somewhere else
now first off you need an understanding
of operating systems
you need to have a basic understanding
of operating systems
like windows or linux now although this
isn't exactly
mandatory this will help you understand
cloud services better
since most of them are based on linux
next up you need to have experience with
programming languages
languages like sql go python csharp.net
and so on
will help you develop cloud-based
applications based on requirements from
your organization
now although this isn't mandatory either
some services do require coding so that
you can use them properly
in the next step we have networking you
need to understand networking
fundamentals
like virtual networks local area
networks wide area networks
networking models and so on now this is
really important because
this will help you understand how the
back-end infrastructure of the cloud
works
after that the most self-explanatory
step learn aws
now you need to focus on learning the
different services that are offered by
aws
now aws provides a year-long free tier
where you get access to several
important services like ec2 and s3
so you can use it to get practical
experience with these services
now you can decide among several
different career paths that are offered
by aws
paths like cloud practitioner cloud
architect
cloud developer operations devops
engineer
and certain some others and finally
you need to be certified by aws you need
to choose from different levels of
certification
that are provided by aws these can help
you showcase your proficiency
in working with different aws solutions
now let's talk about certifications
available in aws
now as you can see on screen there are
three levels four actually
firstly you have foundational level
certification that includes the cloud
practitioner certification
now for this you need to have six months
of basic cloud knowledge
and industry knowledge as well so
basically the cloud practitioner
certification
acts as the starting point for just
about every other job role you want to
take
be it architect operational or developer
then in associate you need to have a
year of experience working with aws
cloud
solving solutions and implementing
solutions
you have options for solutions architect
sysops administrator
developer and so on
and finally you have professional level
certification
now after two years of experience with
the aws cloud you can take up the
certification
you have options of solutions architect
professional and devops engineer
professional
now there are certain specialty
certifications that are provided by aws
these are based on advanced networking
big data
security machine learning and alexa
skill builder
now let's have a look at aws's website
let's go to google search aws
certification
and here you can see that like like i
told you here are the certifications
let's go to the bottom here
and you can see that here all the
certifications that i mentioned
are divided into different levels like i
told you cloud practitioner
architect developer operations and
devops engineer
let's have a look at cloud practitioner
so here you can see the steps you need
to take to become a cloud practitioner
now aws suggests that you take up their
course and then follow it up by taking
their certification test
now similarly let's have a look at how
to become an aws
cloud architect you can select the link
here
so like we saw with cloud practitioner
they give you a set of courses you need
to take
followed up by a certification test
basically you need to first get the
associate level certification and then
move on to the professional level
certification after you've gotten some
experience and knowledge
similarly you can look at other job
roles like developer
very similar and operations likewise
everything else you can see here
now let's go back and talk about the
companies that are hiring in 2020
so this is basically every company
that's hiring in 2020
so you have examples like imdb
lamborghini
adobe bitdefender htc and so much more
this is just the tip of the iceberg and
with that we've reached the end of this
session
i hope you guys found this informative
and helpful thank you for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay updated about more
tutorials
and live sessions thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here